These are foods that are made because of the government helps support these
commodity crops, which are 60% of our calories that people consume them.
The most are the sickest globally. It kills 11 million people a year.
That's like a Holocaust, every single year,
people dying from eating the wrong foods and not eating the right foods.
And it's because our whole agricultural system has been moved to make those
foods which are causing heart disease, diabetes, cancer,
dementia, obviously obesity.
I'm Dave Rubin. And this is the Rubin report.
And joining me today is a doctor who is a leader in the field of functional
medicine, as well as a 13 time, New York times,
best selling author. Uh, and his newest book is food.
Fix how to save our health, our economy, our communities, and our planet.
One bite at a time Dr. Mark Hyman, welcome to the Rubin report.
Thanks for having me, Dave. I think that was my longest intro ever. I mean,
this is a serious updated.
Cause that just hit the list yesterday.
I'm doing this on the timeline. You can see as I edited it right there,
but it said 12 on the progress. Um,
I'm super psyched to talk to you because as I,
as I just said to you before we started getting away a little bit from politics
is always a nice break for me,
but this is not purely away from politics.
So we're going to do a little of that.
It's probably the most political issue of our time,
even though we don't talk about it that way. Yeah.
And, and quite literally you bit off a lot in this title,
because you talk about economics and communities and the planet and all of those
things and how it's related. So before we get into any of that stuff,
how did you get into this field? What made you care about all of this stuff?
Where did it all come from?
That's great. Well, I've always been interested in helping nutrition.
I grew up in Spain. My parents lived there for 11 years after the war.
They missed the whole junk food, fast food,
processed food revolution in America.
And I always grew up eating real whole food.
And in college I lived with a guy who was a nutrition PhD student,
and he introduced me to this whole idea about nutrition against disease. Uh,
and I became a yoga teacher before I was a doctor.
And then I became a doctor and kind of got indoctrinated literally and became,
um, very focused on, you know, traditional good medicine,
but I realized the limits of it.
And I then got sick myself and ended up having to fix myself using
functional medicine, which is looking at systems, looking at root causes.
And after 30 years of sitting in my office, seeing chronically ill patients,
which by the way,
is six out of 10 Americans have a chronic disease that kills
11 million people a year from food.
I realized that food was causing my patients to be sick and that I had to look
at why they were eating the food they were eating. And then I thought, well,
it's the food system? And I'm like, well, why do we have the food system?
It's our food policies.
And then why do we have our policies is because of the food industry influence
driving our policies and some of it's legacy from good intentions.
Then we still have firm policies 15 and seven years ago.
So current to me that I really want to cure my patients.
I have to step back and look at the big picture of what's wrong with our food
system. The impact is causing on disease on our economy,
on social justice issues, poverty, mental health, kids', academic performance,
national security environment, climate.
It's all one problem that is predominantly driven by our food and our food
system. And it's fixable. If food is the cause it's also the cure.
And that's exactly what this book is about. Um.
It's called food fix not food apocalypse.
So we'll, we'll see about that. Give me another 50 minutes here. Um,
so you know, I, I had your buddy max Luke of on,
and he was also talking about how funk, how regular Western medicine,
when his mom got sick, um,
they did not have enough answers or it was as he calls it, diagnose and adios.
You, you just referenced something there about indoctrination and, uh,
relative to Western medicine and how they don't really talk about food.
Can you explore that?
Yeah. One Barry says, you know, um,
the food system produces food with no paying,
no attention to health and the healthcare system treats disease with no
attention to food.
And I think food is the biggest driver of chronic disease is something that, uh,
I've learned as, as a functional medicine doctor,
that food is medicine and can heal, but it also can harm.
And so that's really why I wrote this book was to sort of help our country and
hopefully our global population understand that if we want to deal with some of
the biggest crises we're facing today in America and globally,
we have to focus on the food system. It's the most invisible cause it's,
there's no real conversation about it in the political discourse.
And yet it's probably the biggest political issue of our time.
So since we're having the conversation right now,
what are some of just like the basic things we should know about the foods we're
eating and what we're being forced fed that we shouldn't eat,
maybe some things that we should be incorporating.
Exactly.
So how we grow food from the seed to how we produce food
and processed food to how we eat it and how we waste it is driving
so much of our issues.
So the food we're producing predominantly today is what we call ultra processed
calories or ultra processed food. What is that? It's food made from a fuse,
simple ingredients, refined white flour, high fructose corn syrup,
and other corn additives and ingredients and refined soybean oil that are turned
into literally hundreds of thousands of processed foods that are all made from
the same ingredients that are different colors,
sizes and shapes of food like extruded substances.
And the frightening thing is the data is not fresh. That's what you're doing.
They're not fresh ingredients. You might even recognize you read.
If you cover the front of a Pop-Tart or a corn dog of the box,
you probably could barely tell the difference in the ingredients, right?
And these are foods that are made because of the government helps support these
commodity crops, which are 60% of our calories that people consume them.
The most are the sickest globally. It kills 11 million people a year.
That's like a Holocaust, every single year,
people dying from eating the wrong foods and not eating the right foods.
And it's because our whole agricultural system has been moved to make those
foods which are causing heart disease, diabetes, cancer,
dementia, obviously obesity. And it's frightening to me when I was born,
there were 5% of Americans who are obese. When I graduated medical school,
it was less than 20%.
There was not a single state that had an obesity rate over 20%.
Now it's 42% and most States have obesity rates over 40%.
That's 42% of Americans are obese, 75% overweight.
It's going to be one in two people in 10 years, that will be obese,
not just overweight. And this is crippling our economy.
We now have one in $3 in Medicare is spent for diabetes
alone. Our higher chronic disease epidemic.
80% of Medicare costs are from chronic disease.
We have one in three federal dollars that are spent on Medicare sooner.
It will be one in two. I mean,
Medicare for our company would be the biggest company in the world with a $1.3
trillion a year budget. Wow. And, and a lot of that is unnecessary.
80% of that is unnecessary is caused by the food and the food system.
So you mentioned the way our policies going back decades sort of led to some
abuse. Um, is there like a moment? Yeah. So here's what.
It happened. You know,
nobody was like a big cabal of evil food companies that got together and said.
I'm glad you started with that because I think that's right.
People think that it's,
it's like these evil companies or the evil government that sit down and how do
we screw over the most amount? Okay.
It's the unintended consequences of good intentions, right?
So after the world war II, there was a lot of hunger in the world.
There was a need to produce a lot of starchy calories,
which we thought were good sources of carbohydrates and energy to fuel a growing
population. And so industrial agriculture came onto the scene with,
you know, mass mechanization with intensive use of fertilizers,
pesticides herbicides, which no one knew were bad at the time. I mean,
silent spring was written in the sixties by Rachel Carson,
which expose a harm of DDT and pesticides that was eliminated till the
seventies. Uh, and we didn't know that fertilizer,
woulds destroying oceans and lakes and rivers and killing, you know,
hundreds of thousands of tons of fish every year.
Did really nobody know. I mean, I don't, I don't.
I believe that people really said, Oh, these pesticides,
we're going to kill people. We're going to use them anyway.
Or that glyphosate is going to cause cancer and destroy our microbiome.
You think these companies, they really just, they thought they had answers.
Yeah, of course.
Create a, uh, a food for a growing population. Uh,
but then people started to understand these things.
And then the cat was out of the bag and they didn't want to lose the,
the business and the profitability of growing food in this way.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about lifestyles,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our lifestyle playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist,
they're both right over here and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.